like a lot of people i think when i was
younger collected cards i would buy
packs and i had binders filled with
different baseball and basketball cards
and i had not thought of these cards in
15 or 20 years i assumed as the internet
came along and people got interested in
other things that these had fallen out
of favor much like beanie babies and
pokemon and all sorts of interests of
you all through the colorful pages of
zubaz but then i started digging around
and i saw that the market not just for
trading cards but all those things had
begun to explode five grown men were
fighting over trading cards outside the
brookfield target really over the last
year and a half two years the value of
this stuff has been skyrocketing when
players got hot before their prices will
take a spike but this was happening in
every sport and the percentages were
insane like
never seen before i have customers that
used to hide their sports cards
girlfriend comes and like you don't know
they collect cards but now it's cool
entertainers are collecting cards people
are filming it and they're getting
thousands of people like the video
gamers you know watching them play games
you all got a chancey oh snap we're now
cool
[Music]
the boom in the value of trading cards i
think has its roots in the
great recession in 2007-2008
where you saw a lot of people lose a lot
of money it was the worst day on wall
street since the crash of 1987. you saw
investors start to look into alternative
asset classes other places to put their
money so that they could diversify not
be too susceptible to crashes in the
market that sorts of things which is why
you've seen money flood into everything
from sneakers to music copyrights nfts
these non-fungible tokens pokemon cards
beanie babies trading cards all these
other places where people can invest
because they believe that they're going
to appreciate with time
i decided to start figuring out what's
going on the more i dug around i was
really drawn to this one guy ken golden
i am ken golden and i am the founder and
executive chairman of golden auctions
he's just a character talks a million
miles a minute he knows everything and
everyone if i want to go send out an
email i can reach 500 000 people at a
touch of a button he loves to kind of
show off how much he knows he goes live
on instagram all the time to do what's
called a break with his son where you
open up a pack of cards we are back okay
25 000 no bids for an ultra rare kobe
bryant one of one this is
1951 rookie card of mickey mantle let me
repeat that ken golden is one of a
handful of people who have lived and
breathed the sports collectibles market
for 40 or 50 years i've been doing this
since 1978
okay literally buying and selling since
i was 12 years old
less than 50 of these exist in the world
the holy grail of baseball cards the
t206 honest wagner he's done more press
around trading cards than just about
anyone i got the idea of doing a major
baby with auction so i contacted the
babe with birth placement museum and
we came up with a deal for about 20
years i went on networks including uh
you know the most famous one qvc network
and when i sold product i was literally
the expert that went on and spoke about
the product ken golden the ceo of
scoreboard are you with us i am and
we're ready to go on this one
came up with the idea for golden
auctions really in early 2000 i had
always been doing things in the trading
card industry in the collectible
industry from owning a card manufacturer
to uh you know selling sports
collectibles
golden auctions was a second or third
tier auction house behind some of the
biggest dogs like heritage auctions but
he made a decision a few years ago to
really focus on contemporary cards and
on cards outside of baseball to fish
elsewhere
in trading cards you've got two
different markets you've got vintage and
you've got modern
when i was a kid and collected cards all
people cared about was the vintage cards
they wanted ty cobb they wanted babe
ruth they wanted mickey mantle nowadays
people collecting are much younger and
what they want is the cards of the
players that they're watching today
there was something going on and you
know i really threw myself into the
modern market we were lucky enough to
get a collection in 2019 that we started
selling of uh some very rare basketball
cards i probably got the better end of
the deal with a card called a logo man
with lebron james and michael jordan i
privately sold that card
for nine hundred thousand dollars
which broke the record
not only for the highest price modern
card of all time but the highest price
basketball card of all time i think it
really
you'll lit a fire
here we go
hello
sports card investors and welcome back
to the show floor of the national sports
collectors convention 2021. the buzz in
this room is tremendous i've been coming
to these shows for more than 15 years
and this is unlike anything i've ever
seen this is off the charts traffic to
3x sales for the first two days every
day getting progressively busier it's a
sign of how healthy the hobby is
so some of the cards that have set
records in the past year or two include
rookie cards for yana sante kakumpo the
milwaukee bucks forward lebron james
kobe bryant luka doncic when players got
hot before their prices doubled
which is normal a guy comes up from the
minor league or a players score 62
points in a game you know their prices
will take a spike but this was happening
in every sport and the percentages were
insane like
never seen before for example a michael
jordan rookie card that was 25 000
in 2019 was 40 000 in march 2020 and
then within two months it hit a hundred
thousand dollars for the first time ever
and then it came back down and then it
went all the way up to hitting seven
hundred thousand dollars in at our hour
auction we remembered selling luca
donches in the last nationals
for
77
by the time we got back and we did the
next show
there were 300
the prices went up to 1500 to
then 3 000. that was when we're like
we're gonna sell the valuations of all
these go through the roof in kind of a
12 to 18 month span during the pandemic
like the eight highest selling cards of
all time all happened
if you go all the way back trading cards
started as inserts in other things they
were sort of a means of marketing
tobacco companies put trading cards in
cigarette packages then in the 50s tops
put trading cards in gum and other candy
that becomes so successful that they
become primarily a trading card company
then all of a sudden in the late 1980s
starting in really 1987 and 88 you know
it was
crazy tops downrivers flear score the
names go on
then upper deck came in and in 1989
opera came out with a product that
revolutionized the industry and it had
card number one as ken griffey jr there
it is wow
you know everyone thought it was limited
but what they didn't realize was upper
deck kept printing
and printing
and printing the card manufacturers had
the mistaken thought
that they were making a commodity and
they started treating it like a
commodity so what they would do is
produce to order if they had two billion
cards ordered they literally would
create two billion cards not thinking
that if they create so much product and
the product goes stale the price is
going to go down you know here comes
1994 and then all of a sudden it's a
baseball strike world wars and acts of
god couldn't do to baseball with 28
owners and 700 players have done they
killed off the balance of the season
everybody stopped buying cards
hundreds of millions of dollars of cards
started getting returned to all the
manufacturers that glut of supply led to
kind of a crash in prices
in the late 1990s luckily
there was a rebirth
most of the major sports league set up
exclusive deals with one manufacturer
and that manufacturer is intentionally
controlling supplies so that that does
not happen again they started using
insert cards and chase cards you know
kind of like golden tickets that is a oh
they know that the contemporary
collector wants something unique
privileged scarcity they will create a
one-of-one card
or they will create a limited set of 10
cards because they know that the
interest for that will be so great you
literally can spend five dollars on a
pack and pull out something that's
literally worth a million dollars oh my
god oh my god i think that they have it
down to a better science and the risk is
more spread out over a number of
products that if they realize they laid
an egg with one product you know with
overproducing they can immediately
compensate and react to ensure that that
does not happen in future products the
second anything goes on the shelves of
any of the major retail locations it's
gone i got there pretty much right when
they opened it was the first one in line
as long as that keeps happening we're in
good shape
when you look at the landscape today
tops has the exclusive license for major
league baseball properties upper deck
has the exclusive license for the nhl
but panini has a baseball license with
the players association and they have
the exclusive nfl and mba license and
the growth of the market over the past
10 years has really been in basketball
more than any other sport
because of the international nature of
basketball
so panini with the lockdown on that they
took the architecture of most of their
products from an upper deck product that
was produced starting in 2003 called
exquisite you know they came out with a
card called a logo man where they took
the nba logo man patch off a uniform and
put it on a card and they only made one
one card for example the lebron james
ultimate logo man which is like the most
sought after rookie of lebron james one
of one we just appraised it for somebody
for 15 million dollars
15 million dollars for a card produced
in 2003. uh they also came up with
something called the uh rookie patch
autograph where they made a trading card
and then they took a patch of his uh
game used jerseys they put it on 99
different cards and then they had them
had the player sign it i think it's a
lot of things coming together with psa
with grading
it brought a big audience more than
before
grading is basically our authentication
system and way of putting a set value on
a card based on the condition
my name is steve sloan i'm the president
of psa which stands for professional
sports authenticator we authenticate
porch memorabilia and collectibles
specifically trading cards as our
largest category and that spans the
world of vintage baseball cards to ultra
modern basketball cards in addition to
tcg cards like pokemon yu-gi-oh magic
gathering being the first company to
offer a third-party authentication and
grading industry has really gathered
around our standards so the four
categories for grading is
centering which help you know best
condition is basically 50 50 and then
the surface if you have any dents
scratches those are the two things you
look for the corners if it's dull or
sharp or rounded those are the
categories edge is basically if there's
any lines and any issue with the edge of
the card
psa is basically grading your card if
you have a 500 jordan rookie before now
it's obviously a lot more if you get it
in top condition it becomes a gem mint
basically and now our psa 10 just sold
for 840 000
and that's
a big game changer
while we're handling cardboard and not
precious stones or gems it is the same
type of mentality for the people who've
submitted them to us this is a priceless
item with someone out there whether it's
a family heirloom or a recent purchase
that's gotten them really excited in the
space so you know the time taken by psa
to grade is a really important part of
the overall industry
there's high demands on rare cards but
not everyone could afford those rare
cards
one thing we saw that came into the
marketplace really in
2019 is these fractionalized share
companies
fractional ownership at least as it
pertains to trading cards is a
relatively new concept that only became
possible a few years ago the way that it
works is that mythic markets or any
other fractional company acquires a
physical asset let's say a black lotus
which is a magic card we create a
company black lotus llc for instance
that exists solely to own that card that
company is what is being broken up into
shares securitized and then an ipo is
held for people to invest in shares of
that company and then we open up a
secondary trading market where shares of
that can be traded between investors
effectively it is no different than
investing in your favorite traditional
stock in the stock market apple google
microsoft facebook whatever technically
you're not investing in the card itself
for instance what you're investing in is
a company that exists solely to own that
one thing that one card for the people
who love this stuff but don't have a
million dollars to plant into a single
card for instance this is a great way to
invest in the things they love something
that they have intimate knowledge of
that you know may be an advantage over
those that don't have
that that same knowledge it has
especially over the last um you know 18
months outperformed the market and gold
and real estate and other alternative
assets that they could otherwise invest
in are broadly available to investors
the market
won't always be a rocket ship so you
also look to diversify
we've just recently announced that we
are launching our first ever comic book
uh video game and uh you know tcg
trading card games like pokemon yu-gi-oh
magic the gathering and so on
the rapid surge in prices definitely
leveled off in the past few months what
we don't know is whether this is a
bubble that will slowly deflate and it's
a sort of a passing enthusiasm or
whether this is as most the people in
the industry would hope sort of a new
asset class and the prices will just
fluctuate much like stocks fluctuate
inflation is becoming more apparent and
people need to get out of cash in order
to get into some alternative asset
this market is in its early innings and
is only going to get bigger
you